nous accueillons aujourd'hui sarrassat
l'un et marie chloé racines les deux
réalisatrices da perte de vue un
documentaire sur le phénomène d'érosion
qui pourrait mener à la disparition des
îles de la madeleine
ce documentaire est programmé aux airs
idm les rencontres internationales du
documentaire de montréal qui se
tiendront en ligne sur internet du 12
novembre au 2 décembre bien sûr à cause
de la pandémie
bonjour sarah bonjour et chloé alors que
sarah et marées club et je vais vous
poser les questions à vous deux vous
allez répondre quand vous roulez d'où
est partie l'idée de votre film sur
l'évasion vers le risque de disparition
des îles de la madeleine
mais ça s'est fait comme en deux parties
marie tu vas pas te raconter la
diffusion parti mais je pense que à la
base est due à un désir de nous deux de
parler d'une certaine jeunesse qui
vivait dans un environnement on veut
vraiment décrire comment et quand on est
jeunes de ton grand nombre un peu ce
culte et nos valeurs et notre façon de
vivre notre conscience pictures pas
qu'on avait comme le désir de créer un
projet sur cette thématique là puis un
ep mariko est allé aux nomades un oui
mais c'est ça en fait chez al yousif
j'ai rencontré des jeunes choyés dans un
dans un café l'aveu puis on rencontre
aussi jeune le est vraiment donné envie
de parler de cette jeunesse le qui
habitent sur un territoire qui
complètement différent du nôtre est donc
en italie - et ça va faire la recherche
pendant trois semaines et ozil en hiver
2018 puis et c'est là qu'on ait fait des
entrevues avec avec toute une classe en
fête de l'école de bassin une gêne au
mollet puis s est lui que les jeunes
nous ont vraiment parlé sans qu'on leur
demande de leur territoire et de ce qui
se passe des changements qu'ils voient
et au niveau environnemental
qu'est que c'est là qu'on s'est dit
comme acquis ouais c'est sur le sujet au
final c'est ce qui les habitaient jour
après jour etc c'est vraiment de ce
qu'on a envie de parler donc mais vous à
ce moment-là vous n'aviez pas encore
idée de du phénomène de l'érosion et du
respawn il pourrait les îles de la
madeleine où vous l'aviez déjà déceler
avant
en fait on était quand même au courant
que ça se passait parce que c'est ça moi
je t'ai allait quand même mérité avant
sarah mais si vraiment c'était pas notre
idée à la base de parler de l'érosion
cette époque on pensait pas que c'était
aussi groupe
on savait pas non plus que les jeunes
étaient autant au courant s'il y avait
quelque chose de vraiment original à
dire sur le sujet on s'est rendu compte
que fait un train fait pas leur mode de
vie fait qu'on avait peur de l'aborder
dans le fond avant de parler des jeunes
le phénomène de l'érosion pour moi c'est
quelque chose de naturel donc pourquoi
pourquoi s'alarmer
qu'est ce qui vous fait à l'armée est ce
que c'est l'érosion elle même qui au
bout de 300 en trois ou quatre ans jean
ça va faire disparaître les i ou bien
c'est la vitesse de d'érosion parce que
à terme les ils disparaîtront que ce
soit avec l'intervention de l'homme de
l'humain ou non c'est ce que le
phénomène de l'érosion est de plus en
plus intense est de plus en plus graves
à cause de l'activité humaine
la questure que les retours ça que je
toutes les côtes au québec c'est un
enjeu qui est assez connue partout sur
la côte nord en gaspésie îles de la
madeleine
mais le fait que du changement
climatique est causé par l'activité
humaine en fait rend l'érosion et la
madeleine plus grave picom c'est une île
ces insulaires mais ça ça ça se voit
beaucoup plus parce que le territoire
rétrécit de plus en plus de ça va même
jusqu'à déplacer des maisons ça va même
jusqu'à à détruire des routes et c'est
vraiment lié à leur mode de vie
donc on y voit les les conséquences
directes mais qui sont de plus en plus
rares il même le honda mme zahra dire
quand ça va devenir de plus en plus
dangereux parce que si c'est
incontrôlable d'une certaine façon ces
puits ou un fax est pas mal à la vitesse
à laquelle cinq des poids de plus en
plus après les années pourquoi vous avez
choisi de le regard des enfants
juste une question un peu classique mais
je vais avoir entre votre réponse est
simple mais c'est quand même une bonne
question parce que c'est vrai qu'on
aurait pu parler de n'importe qui parce
qu'il ya aussi ton n'avons pas beaucoup
de souvenirs dans le film qui dit on
aurait pu aussi y aller avec
plus âgé qui voit cette terre là où lyon
a pris toute leur vie mais je pense que
c'est vraiment c'est une question d'art
dont le sait vraiment au début on
voulait parler la jeunesse parce que
c'était un sujet qui nous intéressait à
lasbordes espèce de naïveté qui venait
aussi avec les réflexions c'est que ça
tombe vraiment et a donné comme cela
j'ai l'impression que dès le début du
film on a fait le choix de prendre les
enfants de 11 12 ans parce qu'on
trouvait qu'il y avait une certaine à
cet âge là il ya une certaine naïveté
qui est propre à l'enfance mais aussi
une conscience puis une idéologie qui
commencent à contrôler que c'est
vraiment une tranche d'âge qui nous
appelaient qu'on aimait beaucoup
chaque à la basse et partie de cette
tranche d'âge les qui par la suite on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
beaucoup de films y représentait pas
nécessairement ce que les jeunes pensent
elles passent à la crise
environnementale ou par rapport à leur
territoire ou juste laisser la parole
aux jeunes c'est souvent ça va être des
adultes à travers les médias savait
qu'on trouve et qui avait comme un
important vol par un film qui laissait
la parole aux jeunes
puis c'est pour ça aussi d'ailleurs
quelle heure je fais mon leur laisse la
parole à travers une lettre qu'ils
écrivent à travers des souvenirs
vous avez donc vous avez choisi edouard
julia et yvon gabriel est ce que c'était
est ce que ces lettres c'était leur
propre lettre ou où ça devrait nous un
moi personnellement j'ai été surpris par
leur maturité douce alors venir est ce
que c'est c'est un discours qu'ils ont
appris chez leurs parents à l'école où
est ce qu'ils ont vu greta d'une bague à
la télé commencez vous n'aurez venu
c'est cette conscience et j'ai envie de
dire beaucoup par leurs parents mais à
la base beaucoup avec le fait qu' ils
seront en touriste ils peuvent pas s'en
échapperont le fond le c1
un discours qui ont donc pas ce qu'il
voit jour après jour ils vivent ils
avoir à côte disparaître l'année d'après
à la plage privée et que c'est sûr que à
l'école aussi on entend beaucoup parler
un organisme qui s'appelle attention
fragile qui font des ateliers à chacun
et à l'école pour les conscientiser en
fait sur l'avenir mais ils seraient les
problèmes qui auraient tous donc mai
et l'être à la base c'est un exercice
qu'on avait les fêtes avec la profession
de 6e année à l'école où les jeunes
veaux puis on leur avait demandé de
décrire les îles à quelqu'un qu'ils
auraient jamais duré jamais pu les voir
parce qu'ils étaient disparus puis avec
cette idée la veille c'est de voir les
lieux qu'ils allaient ressortir les
lieux qui était important pour un pays
qui décrit vraiment pour que les gens
puissent quand même avoir une image
mentale de ckoi les îles etc c'est sûr
que c'est là qu'on a travaillé avec
tueur mais met toute la base des deux
sas apport de leurs apports du
dissentiment qui selon m en tout cas
vraiment moi j'ai été surpris quand
maturité je le répète
votre film sera sera présenté aux et
reader les rencontres internationales du
documentaire de montréal pour vous c'est
le meilleurs festivals au monde
alors qu'est ce que ça vous fait d'être
jeune réalisatrice et de participer à de
ne prendre part à ce festival
on dit que c'est mal au monde c'est
vraiment personnelle mais je pense que
c'est propre à nous parce que ça a
toujours été un peu un rêve que notre
film soit priori dmp là c'est comme si
on leur donne notre première mondiale
fac c'est vraiment là la première place
puisque notre homme va être projeté puis
en plus on est en amour avec ce festival
de fac est sûr que ça ça compte beaucoup
pour nous puis on est très fier de ça
mais à la base c'est personnellement
moyen 1e c'est ce qui me fait aimer le
cinéma c'est ce qui m'a fait découvrir
le documentaire montréal c'est mon
festival préféré à chaque année je suis
au rendez vous c'est sûr que cette année
c'est un peu particulier à cause de la
pandémie
on aurait vraiment aimé pouvoir le
présenter en vrai mais ça change pas le
le symbole d'à priori dmp de pouvoir le
partager à travers plusieurs autres
réalisateurs qui sont incroyables du
film avec m c'est vraiment inspirant
tout s'est fait tacler peau c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'incroyable pour
nous là on est vraiment contente
ah c'est sûr que ça fait du bien aussi
d'avoir un nul une reconnaissance pour
notre film parce que depuis le début et
on fait ça comme arthur en fait le tout
financé nos pieds
on ne m'ont pris avec et des
collaborateurs et ils ont vraiment la
fin du projet tout mais on n'a aucune
reconnaissance des personnes on sait pas
si une autre firme et voûtée en vaut la
chandelle et tout c'est sûr qu'ils
devaient d'abord comme une espèce de
reconnaissance de notre festival
répliqué ou deux mais ça fait ça fait
une grande joie alors vous quand vous
faites votre film j'imagine que vous
êtes vous avez étudie cinéma vous aimez
le cinéma donc quand vous faites vos
films vous les faites pour les grands
écrans mais avec la pandémie votre film
va passer en ligne est ce que ça ne vous
frustre pas un peu en tant que
réalisatrice
ouais ben france alors qu'on en entende
un luxe et son cas en la piquant et en
envoyant notre hymne cet ennui mais on
savait qu'il y avait des grandes chances
qu'ils s'assoient sur petit écran et
c'est sûr qu'une outils à bord le temps
de faire le mix on n'est jamais vu
naître le film sur grand écran avec les
spectateurs
réfection qui ont fait tout un peu de
cinéma pour pouvoir revivre ce en montée
avec vent jean pierre mendés diction
ensuite donc
donc si c'est assez sûr qu'ils utilisent
sur petit écran
selon le vu plein de fois le nôtre film
sur un écran de montage le petit 6
c'est comme pour les mains mais le
moindre sentiment c'est certain mais au
moins le fait que ce soit en ligne
amiens que plus de gens vont pouvoir le
voir si tout le monde aux îles de la
madeleine qui serait descendu à montréal
dans la salle de la cinémathèque pour
regarder notre sélection qui ça donne un
peu plus de visibilité de coups au
québec ça pose la question de toutes les
plates formes plus ou est ce qu on en
est rendu dans le visionnement du cinéma
pide des oeuvres visuelles cc c'est à se
demander est ce qu'on devrait revisiter
nos formes de projection mais si on veut
un peu plus personnellement par rapport
à notre film c'est sûr que c'est un peu
décevant parce qu'on aurait aimé se
vivre l'expérience c'est nous qu'on
écrit le film on le crée avec le son
d'une salle avec la projection avec les
couleurs avec pour que tout soit en
grand
p craint donc c'est sûr que c'est un peu
décevant de paul vivre comme ça pour la
première fois maire mais c'est pas s est
pas perdue je pense qu'on va le faire
quand même éventuellement mais j'imagine
que vous n'allez pas refuser si votre
film est diffusé sur netflix par exemple
je donne un exemple
à ce moment là écoutez je vous remercie
beaucoup donc sarah salem et marie chloé
racines et de réalisatrice du
documentaire à perte de vue qui sera
présenté aux horaires idm le 9 novembre
et ce sera en ligne à cause de la
pandémie je le remercie beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
merci beaucoup